hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hardware video and this one is going to
be a detailed hardware overview of the
relatively new zune hd now this is a
device that has come out not too long
ago that i've been using quite a bit
that i'm really interested in and that i
feel the need to give you a hardware
overview for in the event of any uh
hardware related accessories i might
review in the future
so let's just go ahead and not take a
look around the hardware so on the
bottom of the zoom hd is your 3.5
millimeter headphone jack and your usb
2.0 port so that that's where data will
transfer although there is wireless sync
that's where data will transfer and
that's how you will charge
on the right hand side of the zuni hd
it's blank but if you might notice
there's a little ridge something that
case makers have been really excited
about to make something for the zoom hd
that takes part uh takes into account
this little use of a ridge on the zoom
hd hardware so that's pretty cool
on the top of the zoom hd of course is
your hardware button
and on the left hand side of the zoom hd
you have a volume switch and this volume
switch will actually bring up playback
controls on your 3.3 inch oled display
and i'll be obviously talking about the
display more often as is something
that all hardware makers should take
note of so in order to turn the screen
off like i showed you use that power
button up top
so that is a general look at the zoom hd
if we flip it over here to the back
you'll notice a couple of things i do
have the wrap saw on it that i showed
you guys the video installation of so it
is is very close to the actual look it
does provide a matte finish and it i
think it does look really nice
on the bottom left and right there are
screws on the zoom hd not really a big
deal for me and not so much a deal
breaker as just a sort of a unique
feature
and it does have a sort of a angled
design and a very very nice screen on
the front
the front screen is a 3.3 inch oled
display that saves a lot of battery and
is extremely responsive and i can get
into this in a hardware review
in the software overview but right now i
just want to leave it at that that it
has an extremely nice reflective glossy
smooth and very responsive 3.3 inch led
display
down here at the bottom you'll see it
says zoom if i can get that to focus it
does say zoom there at the bottom
and that is basically it so you can use
any 3.5 millimeter headphones that will
work with your ipod touch or your iphone
with this exact mp3 player inside you do
have an accelerometer so when you open
uh something that is sensitive to the
movement of it it'll it's definitely
extremely responsive the nvidia tegra
chip that is inside this mp3 player is
also really really powerful
as uh that is shown with the
applications and the browsing and 3d
gaming and picture tilt so that is very
cool
so that has been a brief hardware
overview slash macro focus test for this
new camcorder so i hope you guys like it
and any feedback is appreciated so thank
you for watching this hardware overview
and i will talk to you guys in the next
video as usual thank you for watching
peace
you